- My first boyfriend was on RuneScape.
I think I was like 10 or 12.
I don't even remember.
You know I don't know how old he was.
I don't, you know it
could have been anything.
(upbeat jingle)
- Today we are revisiting
some of our favorite
old computer games.
Are they computer games?
They're like internet games.
- RuneScape.
- I was a Club Penguin kid.
- Neopets consumed all of my life.
- Just made food in random places.
You can do that in RuneScape.
You can do anything.
- I hope that they haven't updated Neopets
for the new generation.
I'm hoping that it's like
the Space Jam website.
It just stayed where it was.
- I just hope I log on
and I'm like still alive
and I have all my money.
- My name is scarletsam1.
- Wishlaugh118.
- Mayarox12345.
- Linzrox35.
- Korndidyredux, password reduxbaby123.
- The loading bar is the same.
Nothing's changed.
- Everything is still the same.
Is this still a functioning website.
- Ooh there's zombies.
Were there zombies last time?
- Oh Kacheek.
Oh and I remember you, Meerca.
(gasps) Wow, all my friends are here.
- There's a Puzzle Park, a
Skatepark, and Puffle Wild.
I didn't have that.
- (gasps) There I am.
Wait why am I not wearing armor?
- I thought w would record, I was wrong.
- Middle of excitement, I am excited.
- 500 meal points to just spin a wheel?
I have Neopets to feed.
- Cheat, I found it.
News gets a lot of
computers, what a blast.
Played four sixes?
Hell no, I got six in my hand.
You tryin' to get that by me?
Cheating.
- There's like a little cave with a pool
that you can do nothing in.
That would have been a
good improvement to make.
One room with something in it.
- What else do you do on this game
other than cook fish?
- It's getting really dark.
Ooh it got light again.
Whoo, okay, maybe some enhancements.
The sun will go out and
away, just like real life.
- I forgot how terrible Flash is.
The patients that I had as a kid
for things to load is amazing.
- Play Find Four with me.
Okay he's not playing Find Four with me.
I'm not wasting my time on Bryan.
- I forgot what my name is.
- I've never battled before.
Let's see if my child will make me proud.
It's doing a lot of damage to me.
I died.
Now I feel sad.
- Cornball!
(gasps) I found it.
So you throw this ball
and then something happens
and it explodes.
For how long I waited to find this game,
it kind of sucks.
- This game used to be much more populated
in the town that it is now.
Back then it was like
yeah, pass a leprechaun,
pass a cow.
- Oh someone just asked me
about they want to be friends.
Yes, desperately.
- So playing RuneScape
again was kind of nostalgic.
- I found the same joys
I found when I was a kid.
- Now that kind of sucked.
(laughs)
Somethings were just as exciting,
just as fun as I remembered.
And some of that shit was boring.
- There seems to be a
lot more theatrics to it,
which is really cool.
- They have not changed anything,
so I'm assuming nobody works at Neopets.
- I know that they're
getting rid of the website
and just making it a mobile device.
Probably because, I think,
more kids go on their phone now
than a computer.
- If you're out there
and you're watching this,
and you want to go play Neopets.
You have my information.
And don't change the password.
Let's make this a community.
I want a big ass house,
with a lot of fruits,
and I want so many Neopoints.
- I just clicked on this well.
And that's my shit.
That's where it all is.
That's the girl I know.
Mhmm.
Oh my god, yes!